ya effectivement une double morale en
double de jugement parce qu'on a
tendance à penser à la chine comme les
méchants de l'histoire aux états unis
comme les gentils alors que finalement
lorsque les états unis disent qu'ils ne
veulent pas de tik tok
ils ne disent pas que personne n'a le
droit de toucher aux données de leurs
citoyens
ils sont en train de dire qu'il n'ya que
eux qui peuvent toucher aux données de
leurs citoyens
finalement cette question touche à la
protection des données à la souveraineté
numérique à l'ingérence étrangère sur la
politique nationale et elle touche aussi
à des questions de censure à qui est ce
qu'on laisse le choix de quels contenus
peuvent être diffusées et quel contenu
ne peuvent pas l'être
c'est donc globalement un sujet de ceux
de souveraineté et les effectivement
regrettable que d'où le soin tout ça
soit résumé un conflit entre les
etats-unis et la chine où l'on n'a pas
notre mot à dire
[Musique]